hey what's up guys my name is jono now
this video was originally going to be
Genesis it was going to be me working on
the first game that ever made porting it
from java to C plus plus however I kind
of started talking about like Global
variables the static keyword how to make
them like in header files and use them
elsewhere how to ensure you only have
one instance of them which seems like an
easy topic but you'll see that it goes
pretty deep and lots of people aren't
really sure how they should go about
creating Global variables in C plus plus
that can be used absolutely anywhere
inside your application and like there's
so many different keywords like no
keyword then there's like static there's
inline there's extern like what do these
all mean so what I decided to do with
this video is turn it into something
that would hopefully just be like a
standalone kind of video unrelated to
the rest of the series that specifically
focuses on how you can make Global
variables so enjoy so now all we really
need to do is go through and create like
every instance of Sprite kind of like
we're doing here in Java uh but we're
going to do that obviously here now
we're inside a header file so it's worth
noting that when it comes to like our
strategy to create a bunch of these
Sprites it might seem like something
really really simple that no thought
should be given to but you actually do
have to think about it a little bit
funnily enough because the thing is this
isn't just like in Java where we can
just create a bunch of static instances
like this and we're kind of done and
just make them public static you know
they're inside the Sprite class like
that's fine right because at the moment
we're not inside any kind of class right
we're just inside kind of global space
and so what happens is if we create
a Sprite like this then every single
file that includes this
pedophile right so like we'll have to
obviously include this in the game in
fact we can go ahead and do that now
right if I include sprite.h inside
game.cbp obviously what's happening is
this header file just gets copied and
pasted in here
so now we're dealing with this stuff
so what happens is if we then include
that sprite.h header file in like say
the renderer or some other class like
the level class because we'll probably
need it in a bunch of different places
potentially right then you can kind of
see what we're doing it's like we're
creating Sprites in every single place
so that's not really what we want to do
because like you can see literally from
the code that I've pasted here that like
what does this code do oh well it
creates like a new Sprite instance so we
don't really want to do that because we
want to have a global kind of variable
now how do you set up a global variable
well we could create it in like a single
CPP file like in game or make a variable
make a CPP file called like Global
variables or whatever that's probably I
would advise against that but anyway
like we could do something like that and
then Mark it as extern everywhere else
so that we don't create copies of it
that's possible
um the other thing that you might think
of is what happens if you make it static
well in fact instead of me just talking
let's actually try this but first before
we dive into all this exciting Global
variable stuff I want to thank
brilliant.org for sponsoring this video
I'm sure a lot of you probably already
know what brilliant.org is by now but if
you don't it's an amazing website filled
with lots and lots of Great Courses on
various stem topics two particular like
collections of courses I really love and
brilliant are there computer science
courses they can be really really
helpful for beginners they can kind of
teach you to start thinking more like a
programmer and because Brilliance
teaching is like so visual and engaging
like they'll quiz you and all of that
they'll give you these widgets you can
play with see how stuff works it's just
a much more fun kind of interactive
learning experience the other area I
love are their math courses because they
go really really deep from the basics
like everyday math all the way down to
like you know linear algebra and
calculus that can be really useful if
you're making games or rendering and
once again these courses are presented
really visually interactively and
they'll also quiz you to make sure
you're paying attention now what's great
about all this is you don't have to take
my word for it brilliant have a 30-day
free trial that you can use to check out
their entire platform just go to
brilliant.org the channel link will be
in the description below and check it
out for yourselves and if you do like it
brilliant have been nice enough to offer
the first 200 subscribers 20 off an
annual membership huge thank you as
always brilliant for sponsoring this
video so if I include Sprite
in here because this would be a good
practical example I think if I include
sprite.h in here and you can see what's
right is it creates the Sprite
um and then I also go to like renderer
and I include Sprite
let's just try and compile this I
rebuilt it accidentally but let's just
try and compile it and we'll see what
happens all right so you can see that we
got an error and it says one or more
multiply defined symbols found and these
C plus errors like
I feel like I need to create a handbook
of how to deal with tablespo series
because there's there's lots of common
errors that I still to this day remember
how difficult I found them when I was a
beginner but this is this is a very
common one
so one or more multiple defined symbols
found so Sprite right it's telling us
that specifically right it's this
instance of sprite it's called Sprite
it's inside the Genesis namespace this
here is the type right or this here I
guess is the type
uh and then this is specifically the
variable that is already defined in
game.obge so what's happening is you can
see over here that renderer.org
is trying to basically we're trying to
compile the renderer and we notice that
actually we've also okay let me back up
a little bit we're actually not trying
to compile anything we're linking here
right so this is a linking error
um what's happening is we're trying to
link
you know renderer.op to create this
Genesis executable but then we notice
that hang on a minute there's a symbol
called Genesis Sprite that exists
already in game.opge and we see it here
in render.obge so what is dot object is
by the way is every single CPP file that
we have gets compiled into an obj file
during the compilation stage by the way
if you're not sure how the serverless
compiler and Linker works I have some
videos up there that's part of the C
plus series that cover like compiling
linking how C plus even works that
explains all this I made them like six
years ago hopefully they're still
relevant but I think they should pretty
much cover everything and and it
explains this kind of obj stuff and how
the compiler generates this stuff in
detail but basically
um all this APK files become obj files
in the in the compilation stage but then
they have to be linked together into
like an executable in this case into a
program right and during that stage it
notices like because they're all
compiled individually during the
compilation stage doesn't see that oh
you've got multiple defined symbols
because they're in different CPP files
and they're all sent kind of in parallel
really to the compiler they're all
independent from each other but then
when they get linked together it's like
hang on a minute that already exists so
therefore you get a linking error and
specifically you get an error where
um you know it tells you that this is a
multiple defined symbol because it's
found this Genesis Sprite twice
um or well more than once could be many
times but in this case it's twice and
this might seem like a really weird
error because again if you look at
sprite.h it doesn't look like we've done
anything really malicious or really
weird right it's like well I just wanted
to create a global variable but you
can't that's not how it works because
this gets copied and pasted into every
CPP file and suddenly like you can't
have a global variable called Sprite in
two places because you're trying to
create two Global variables with the
same name that's kind of in a way like
writing this that's really what's
happened it's just that when you do it
this way it's obviously in the same file
so therefore it's sent to the compiler
in one go and the compiler can be like
that's wrong but if it's in different
files it's still the same story because
it's a global variable but it's the
compiler can't say that so the Linker
kind of picks it up but anyway
so what do we do well one solution to
this is to make Sprite static if we look
at this
um that works and unfortunately to a lot
of people that might be the solution
like you might be like oh excellent
let's move on and the interesting thing
is like if I did make a Sprite here
called like grass right and it was set
to like some coordinate
and I put static here and I compile it
and I just move on with my life
your program would run correctly there's
nothing like the data is set correctly
you've set it to two seven because
remember at the end of the day what is a
Sprite instance here what are we doing
by creating grass we're just creating
like the numbers two and seven in memory
next to each other like contiguously we
have two 32-bit integers eight bytes
total of memory next to each other two
and seven
that's what we've done so in that sense
your data would be correct and
everything would work however
what you've done is by adding static
here in like a global context right so
we're not within a class this isn't like
you know static Insider class like that
it's static kind of globally just inside
the Genesis namespace what that does is
if you recall what static means in a
global context like this it means the
symbol has internal linkage which kind
of means that it's only visible to the
CPP file that it resides in
so in other words when I include this in
here yeah what that's doing is it's
including my Sprite inside here
statically
so I kind of have something like this
going on this variable is now private to
game.cpp but what do you think happens
when we include sprite.h in like
renderer does it feel like we did the
same story and what's that doing it's
creating a kind of private internal
variable inside this file so what I'm
trying to say
is that we're not creating Global
variables here we're actually creating a
separate copy of this grass variable
This Grass kind of instance of this
struct if you want to think about it
that way we're creating one copy per
file per CPP file that we include this
header file in
so if we include this in 10 different
CPP files we actually have 10 separate
instances of the grass class which
really all that means like the oldest
word of instance is a bit annoying
because that kind of you know I think of
ultrasound to program I want to think of
instance and like class instance and
stuff all that really means is that this
this value 2 comma seven these two these
two unsigned integers you have them in
10 different places in your memory
yeah 10 different copies of this grass
variable because every translation unit
every CPP file that includes this header
file has its own private copy of this
variable which you can see why it would
work though right because well first of
all they're all unrelated so the link is
not going to be like oh you've already
got this defined because it's private to
that CPP file so therefore it doesn't
get linked kind of cross translation
unit but also it would work because the
data is correct
every instance of that grass tile of
this grass Sprite will in fact have
two and seven as it's X and Y
so of course they'll all work
but it's a bit wasteful in the sense
because you're why are you creating 10
different copies of this and I guess
that's kind of why you know in a way it
seems like the correct solution to the
problem but you would never know unless
you actually like have Staples
experience or you understand how this
works already which again to a beginner
you probably wouldn't you'd think that
you've solved the problem oh yeah I just
had to make I just had to add static and
that's kind of what I had before in Java
or whatever so it's like I guess it's
the same no it's not the same it would
be the same if you put into a class
another solution by the way might be to
make and I don't really advocate for
this it could be a class or a struct we
could call it Sprites for example and
then we could actually have stuff inside
here
so you'd kind of address this by just
doing sprite's grass right as long as
it's like static and you actually have
to make it inline static if you wanted
to declare it like that and you have you
have to have sea level 17 for this but
like that's possible and that's
different because if we have it
aesthetic variables had a class there is
only truly one instance of it
yeah so that does what you think it
might probably
but this does not this is not the Zam
this is like the C kind of language in a
way it's not even like objects or you
know static in the in the sense of an
object-oriented language because it's
kind of from C which is not an object
oriented programming language so then
what's the solution to this well
um the real solution that I would use
here is instead of static use the word
inline and by the way if you're ever
unsure of of how this works like I'm
making a pretty bold claim here right
like we have a grass instance per
translation unit
but how do we know that
how do we know that that is in fact true
like you know we are computer scientists
at the end of the day we like to see
results we like to see evidence we like
to perform experiments we have like a
hypothesis but we would like to see that
hypothesis be true right I would like to
test this is what I'm trying to say in a
fancy way so how do I how can I do that
well I can think of two ways you could
do that the first way
is quite simple inside the renderer
class what I can actually do is I can
ask for that Sprite Which I think I just
yeah I just called a grass by the way
what I would probably do is I'd probably
add a namespace here called Sprites or
something just to kind of uh add some
kind of context to this so you don't
have a global variable called you know
Genesis grass because that's a bit weird
is it a tile is this right like you
don't know so if I have if I have that I
can access it like so yeah what I can do
is I can just print out the memory
address of that particular variable so I
could cast it to avoid point I don't
think I have to cast it to a void point
I think the uh C out will just print it
as that but void pointer is kind of
casting it to a typeless pointer and
pretty much every logging Library will
be able to print that because really
kind of what you're doing by doing that
is you're casting it to like in this
case 64-bit architecture to like a un64t
which of course everything can print but
let's just try and print this
um and then I can add like an end line
or a new line character or whatever I
want so I'll add this code here
and then inside game
I'll also add the same thing I'm doing
that both in the Constructor right and
here for some reason I have to include
Photo Stream whatever so game
Constructor which includes Sprite has
that
and exact same code inside the renderer
Constructor as well so if the variables
are exactly the same if they're the same
instance they would have the same memory
address right so let's try and run this
okay our game is running and what do you
know we have two different memory
addresses now they're pretty much side
by side in memory not quiet but close
but they are obviously different now one
other way you could test this
is if you add a Constructor to Sprite
because we'd expect this object to only
be constructed once let's go ahead and
add this in X Y it doesn't really matter
we don't need to set the variables for
this example but I'll just write Sprite
Constructor so let's run that and let's
include iostream all right look twice
yeah so we're clearly constructing two
different instances of it and we clearly
have two different memory addresses of
it so and that's because I've included
it in two files what if I then grab you
know sprite.h and let's include it also
in Genesis app I'm not going to bother
with the print with the printing its
memory address but you should see the
Constructor called three times
so every time you include it it actually
creates that variable you can see that
we've validated that which is great
feels good right as a computer scientist
to actually test something and see the
real result that's what you guys should
really get into the habit of doing by
the way don't believe anything I say
test everything
so now then
yeah if I present an alternative method
so like the solution to this by the way
or what I would do anyway is I would
make this inline which don't ask me why
this is an error uh it's not actually
actually a real error but Visual Studio
is just like whoa what are you doing
okay whatever
might have to restart visual studio and
what inline will do is it will basically
tell it inline is a magical keyword that
does a lot of different things and I
don't want to talk about all the
different you know things that it does
here what inline means in this case is
that you're basically stating that there
should be only one instance of this like
we can't have multiple symbols to find
as this no matter how many translation
units is included in the simple
explanation to this keyword in this case
is there's only one instance of this
right that's it it's here it's as if
this was included in a single CPP file
is kind of what you're saying and so now
if I run it with that inline keyword
check that out
Constructor called once memory addresses
are now equal
so now we truly only have one instance
of this and obviously we're able to
validate that and actually test that by
printing every time we construct the
Sprite and also checking out the memory
addresses of the two different CPP files
the two different translation units
trying to access that kind of one
variable so now with that knowledge in
mind we can go through and obviously add
in all of our kind of surprise and we
can relax knowing that there is in fact
only going to be one instance of each
Sprite across our entire program so yeah
that's kind of like the global variable
situation oh there is one more thing as
I mentioned there are some other ways
that you can kind of create Global
variables you can just Define them in
like one CPP file but without the static
keyword so it's still kind of global and
then use the extern keyword in other CPP
files to reference that kind of to
indicate when you're actually compiling
that one file that it is in fact for
external linkage that's what the
external keyword kind of does so it kind
of will tell the compiler yeah the
variable's not here but that's cool
trust me when it comes to the linking
stage it will be somewhere else but if
you you did want to try that out for
yourselves like it's literally just just
make a variable in global space in a CPP
file like Sprite grass that's that's it
type it outside of any function in a CPP
file and then in another CPP file type X
turns prior grass and then obviously
don't like initialize it with two and
seven or whatever you're initializing it
with and that will also kind of function
as a global variable I do do that
sometimes if I want the variable to be
like a little bit more private so I'm
not kind of I'm not kind of even putting
it in any header files because it's kind
of almost internal to a CPP file but yet
I I need another CPP file to actually
also access it and so I'll Define it
kind of without the extern keyword in
the CPP file that owns it in a way and
then if something else needs to
reference it it will kind of use the x10
keyword to get that I don't know if
that's confusing maybe I'll make a video
about extern as well if you enjoyed the
video please don't forget to hit the
like button check out brilliant at all
slash the channel Link in description
below and I will see you next time
goodbye